Speaker 1: One of the notable people who does
not want an investigation into just what on
earth happened in Washington, D.C. on January
6th as Trump supporters broke into the Capitol,
is Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson.
It's all as much of a riot as you can imagine.
We already discussed earlier in the show that
many in the Republican Party, including Republican
leaders like House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy,
they don't want the January 6th investigation
to happen.
And here, Tucker Carlson praises Kevin McCarthy
for opposing the investigation.
Recall that Tucker Carlson is very much a
man of the people.
He's a populist.
He's for transparency, for accountability.
He's for all of that stuff.
But he doesn't even want an investigation
to take place.
And here he is at a Boeing, Kevin McCarthy.
Speaker 2: This is not a partizan show.
We usually go after Democrats.
Sometimes we go after Republicans.
Recently went after a couple of times the
head Republican in the House of Representatives,
Kevin McCarthy of California, for his living
arrangements.
But we want to be honest above all.
And when politicians do something right, we
want to say so.
Kevin McCarthy, the minority leader in the
House today, did something right and said
he will not support a commission, a 9/11 style
commission to investigate the insurrection
of January six.
Speaker 1: Tucker is defiantly proud of Kevin
McCarthy for opposing a commission to investigate
the January 6th insurrection.
It's also hilarious to hear Tucker say he
doesn't do a partizan show.
I mean, that we could do 15 minutes on that,
but we won't.
Tucker is actually so opposed to an investigation
that he wants to take names of all Republicans
who vote in favor of it because some do plan
to do the exact number is yet unclear.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: The top Republican on the House
Homeland Security Committee is apparently
pushing for this 9/11 style commission.
One anonymous House Republican told The Hill
that anywhere from between 30 and 50 Republicans
might join CatCo in voting for this farce.
What are they voting for?
They're voting to give Nancy Pelosi, Chuck
Schumer and Joe Biden more power.
Power.
They do not deserve power.
They did not win in November.
Republican voters deserve to know the names
of every congressional Republican who votes
for this farce, for the mythmaking that is
being used right now to strip you of your
constitutional rights.
They should know which of the representatives
is playing along with this poisonous hoax.
Speaker 1: So clearly, Tucker, painting this
as some kind of partizan witch hunt when the
truth is that some Republicans are saying
they support the commission because it's being
done in a bipartisan way, not only is there
bipartisan support for the commission, not
only are there bipartisan sponsors for the
commission, the plan right now would be that
the commission would have 10 members, Democrats
get to appoint five.
Republicans get to a point.
Five Democrats appoint the chair and Republicans
appoint the vice chair.
Remember, Democrats control the House.
So the closest you can get to it being perfectly
bipartisan is five and five Democrats because
they control the House, pick the chair, Republicans
get the vice chair and the commission would
only be able to issue subpoenas if they're
signed off on by both the Democratic chair
of the commission and the Republican vice
chair.
So, you know, you couldn't even have a situation
where Democrats alone start issuing all sorts
of subpoenas.
The Republican vice chair would have to be
on board with every single subpoena.
And yet Tucker doesn't like it.
Flames frames it as some kind of farce because,
God forbid, we should ever find out what really
happened on that.
And the causes and the explanations for why
things went down the way they did.
But as we said earlier, if you were complicit,
you wouldn't want to support it.
And defendants accused in the January 6th
Trump riots have actually tried, two of them
at least blaming Fox News and blaming President
Donald Trump.
Neither has worked so far, but blaming Fox
News.
Tucker Carlson is a part of Fox News, and
it seems pretty clear that he would be against
such an investigation because it can't possibly
be good for him.
I'm not saying the probe would bring down
Tucker.
I'm not saying it would get him to lose his
show or get him charged with a crime.
None of that would happen.
But if you're Tucker, it wouldn't be good
for more attention, especially in congressional
hearings, to be on the alleged role of Fox
News in fomenting the riots.
That's very clear.
So it does make sense in that way that Tucker
would be opposed to it.
Now, on the other hand, the White House does
back a January 6th commission and really one
should have been formed on January 7th, may
be May of twenty.
Twenty one is the best we can get at the end
of the day.
If they can't get Republican leadership to
support it, I think they probably will.
But if they can't just go ahead without Republican
leadership, they can find Republicans who
will be on the commission because there's
enough Republicans already at least 20 who
want to do the investigation.
Some of those Republicans will participate
in good faith to try to get some answers.
And the Republicans that remain on the sidelines
screaming, this is a partizan witch hunt.
I don't think they'll make much of a difference.
Democrats should continue to focus on the
70 percent of the country that sees Biden
doing well uncovered and they say, yeah, Biden's
doing well, Unkovic, they see Biden doing
well on vaccination.
And they say, yeah, the vaccination rollout
is going well.
Just proceed, because I think you'll have
an equivalent 70 percent of the country that
understands the importance of doing this probe
and will support doing it.
If you disagree and if you think there's political
risk to going forward without Republicans
in the leadership supporting it, they've got
Republicans that will be on the commission.
Let me know.
I don't see it as a risk.
I think Democrats should move forward one
way or the other.
Let me know your thoughts.